well I think that you can't reform human
nature so what we have to do then is D
materialize the culture in some way and
I I don't talk too much about this
because frankly I haven't really got a
clue as to how you would do that I mean
I know there's nanotechnology and so
forth and so on but what we need to do
is take the matter out of thing 'dom so
that everybody can live in the Frank
Lloyd Wright waterfall house I mean you
cost $9.95 and you buy it at the
7-eleven and take it home and slap it on
and you can live in it so that's why I'm
interested that's why I in spite of my
Nature Boy thrust in most contexts I'm
very interested in virtual reality and
the idea of making the imagination
explicit or interior izing the exterior
world I mean one vision that I've had of
the kind of future utopia is you know if
it opens on a world which looks like our
world of 10,000 years ago
I mean people live tribally they are
physically perfect they're naked they
want for nothing but they appear to have
no material culture whatsoever then when
you shift your point of view so that
you're inside one of these people's
heads you discover that when they close
their eyes there are menus hanging in
space in front of them and by glancing
at these menus with a certain intensity
they are able to make their way into a
culture that is entirely 3 dimensionally
present for them but which nowhere
impinges on the world of
three-dimensional space sort of the idea
that you could have the Vatican Library
installed optionally when you have
dental work you know and then just by
pushing your tongue
over there y-you could view the Fabri on
those or whatever I don't think this is
that far-fetched I mean a lot of money
is going toward this it money can be
made from this and remember I was saying
that we have to figure out unless we're
ready to you know hang the rascals then
we're going to have to figure out some
way to make money out of saving the
world so that capitalism can cease its
rapacious destruction of things and I
think these entertainment technologies
are the way to go I think that what we
should all be trading in in 15 or 20
years from now is ideas and ideas should
be worth more than anything and this is
happening I mean I was impressed at this
we there was a virtual reality
conference here last summer and the
number of people came from Fujitsu and
the Japanese are not dragging their ass
on this stuff the way we are they
understand what it is and the Fujitsu
has a research team of 30 people who
work full-time on virtual reality and
they're sampling data sampling rates and
their equipment was far superior to
anything here the Japanese culture is an
excellent model for this future that
we're trying to move into because what
the Japanese seem to understand that
nobody else understands is they've had
centuries of experience with limited
resource management and you know our
style is you know we're cut it down dig
it out and when it's gone move on
and now we're at the end of our rope
with that we have to manage this thing
like a spaceship limited resources
[Music]
you
[Music]